una de las únicas reservas protegidas de
pantanal se consume poco a poco creada
en los años 1970 para preservar la
biodiversidad en un mes ya perdió 500
kilómetros cuadrados de vegetación lo
equivalente a cinco veces el tamaño de
parís
alexandre y su equipo luchan sin tregua
contra el fuego se propagó desde el
exterior de la reserva
rodeada de granjas de ganadería esto es
peligroso si el viento sopla por aquí es
suficiente una chispa para que el fuego
se propague
cuando hacen una pausa es para tomar un
concentrado de semillas de guaraná para
luchar contra el cansancio a veces son
ayudados por refuerzos de bomberos
militares equipados únicamente con este
camión cisterna alessandro y su equipo
están en el frente hace más de un mes lo
más difícil son los juegos en las
praderas son los más duros de combatir
porque se queman más rápido las llamas
suben mucho más altos más o menos por 10
o 15 horas es imposible acercarse al
fuego los brigadistas son ayudados por
christina la bióloga de 35 años se
encarga de esta inmensa reserva de
difícil acceso donde se cavan caminos
como éste para frenar el avance del
fuego
y aquí arrancar aquí abrimos un camino
que llamamos cortafuegos completamente
despejado cuando el fuego se acerca este
borde no pasa al otro lado que todavía
no sea quemada detenga la pequeña
christina estudia la amplia fauna de la
reserva hoy más que nunca en peligro
sólo los pájaros y algunos mamíferos son
lo suficientemente rápidos como para
escapar de los fuegos los peores desde
hace al menos 15 años
muchas especies mueren los insectos los
reptiles los caimanes las caras las
serpientes que no logran escapar se
quedan dos más el fracaso
jaguares tapires y también osos
hormigueros al menos dos especies en
peligro de extinción viven aquí cuando
escapan del fuego los animales del
pantanal buscan desesperadamente una
fuente de agua pero esta inmensa
explanada una de las zonas húmedas más
grandes del mundo se transformó en un
desierto de polvo y humo estos
veterinarios voluntarios patrullan todo
el día cerca de los focos de los
incendios para rescatar a los animales
en peligro concreta
asustado por el vehículo este quad y un
animal de la familia del mapache trató
de escapar está muy débil
jorge que vino desde el estado de sao
paulo para ofrecer su ayuda se encarga
inmediatamente de el animal no estuvo en
contacto directo con el fuego pero se
quemó las patas caminando sobre la
infinita
ya no tiene piel aquí tampoco perdió
hasta una garra en general se encuentran
muchos animales deshidratados bien sea
porque han estado expuestos al fuego y
al humo porque todo se quemó y no hay
agua cerca entonces se deshidratan por
completo y falleció a pesar de los
esfuerzos de los veterinarios el quad y
finalmente muere unos minutos después
mientras nos dirigimos hacia su base es
frustrante
en realidad la causa es mucho más grande
este cuate o cualquier otro animal que
sabemos es simbólico
todo lo que está ocurriendo va mucho más
allá de vino no es sólo la fauna del
pantanal sino toda la biodiversidad
brasileña la que está amenazada por los
incendios aunque un poco más ocultos los
incendios son mucho más intensos que el
año pasado en ese momento siete mil
kilómetros cuadrados de vegetación
quedaron devastados este año para 9000
la mayor parte de los fuegos se originan
en terrenos deforestados ilegalmente una
realidad que hasta el momento bolsonaro
sigue negando esta historia de la
amazonía en llamas
es una mentira que debemos combatir bajo
su mandato el ministerio de medio
ambiente redujo el presupuesto de la
policía ambiental incluso estuvo a punto
de suspender sus patrullas a finales de
agosto en el estado de matto grosso
una inmensa explanada agrícola separa la
amazonía al norte del pantanal en el sur
los campos de soya de maíz y la
ganadería bovina todos los días gana
terreno y saca las corrientes de agua
que alimentan el tal canal aquí grandes
propiedades privadas se dividen casi
todo
los granjeros han sufrido muchas
pérdidas con los incendios pero son
también los principales sospechosos
celso figueiredo es un criador de ganado
se quemó el 90% de sus 900 hectáreas de
pastizales como todos en la región
recurre a las quemas agrícolas para
fertilizar los suelos una práctica
prohibida en julio por tres meses pero
los granjeros son sospechosos de
infligir la ley bajo el riesgo de caer
en su propia trampa no podría decirles
si algunos provocaron el fuego
en todo caso en mis campos no sólo
respondo por mí mismo la peor sequía que
ha tenido el pantanal desde hace 50 años
sería causada por el desarrollo de la
agricultura intensiva y la deforestación
que la acompaña celso defiende los
beneficios económicos de ese modelo
agrícola sobrevivimos gracias a la
agricultura tenemos una excelente tasa
de crecimiento gracias al cultivo de
soya de maíz y de algodón es nuestro oro
quieren impedir su producción los
incendios ya han devastado 22 mil
kilómetros cuadrados de vegetación desde
el comienzo del año
y las primeras lluvias que esperan sólo
hasta octubre